awesome that sounds amazing sounds great
that does sound like i jumped off the
cliff that aragorn fell off of in the
second movie
oh my god it's a two-foot cliff
did you land on some rocks no it's like
it's literally just a boulder
in the hill and so like on the other
side of the boulder is just
the hill wow i saw i for the first time
last week saw the footage of you jumping
in the shadow of mordor video that you
guys did jumping
into that like river yeah this is on a
rock how
why did you do that ren why would you
what are you thinking
i mean it wasn't that big of a deal
except the problem was that carmichael
was all worried about me so he tried to
insist on me not doing it by covering
the rock in water
without telling me oh my gosh so i don't
even know he did that so i went and
jumped and i landed my
feet slipped out because it was [ __ ]
wet and he was like i was trying to get
you to not do it
carmichael you're an idiot sometimes you
just made it unsafe yeah he just made it
super dangerous i was pissed did you get
injured at all no i was totally fine but
i got wet because i fell in the freaking
creek it seemed like it was pretty like
you remember that i don't well i
remember jumping in the creek for the
fish
for filming yeah it was that same creek
remember when like we got up to the
front and like when you get like
freaking mindset
i remember that little like ruin yeah
that was that's the spot yeah that's
fun yeah and there's a bit there right i
jumped down
onto a rock and it was like it was like
a pretty big drop i don't remember it
was like it was like a seating it
wasn't super big but by the way it was
fake fake fish sucks yeah yeah it would
have been sick to actually like
fish was real no it wasn't it was like a
let me rephrase prop fish
the fish that you were fishing for in
the water was a real fish
oh really it was one that we bought
earlier that day from a fish market
but in the final video when you're we're
all out in the field and you whip out
the fish because you thought it was your
knife that was a cg fish
we didn't know if that was an effect we
were going to be doing or not so
in the moment you actually pulled out a
knife wait didn't someone randomly do
that
kevin cummerford did it it looked good
yeah because i never knew
cg yeah cuz kevin is an amazing cg
artist
and he was like we were like hey can you
do this shot he's like yeah and like a
day later
we had two different shots one where you
whip it out and the other one you're
like
kevin works at stress level zero working
on uh
bone work bone works yeah for those of
you guys i can't wait for whatever they
put out next
without some sort of a quest based
boneworks physics
type game i'm very excited yeah me too
it's so crazy how well they did
on that like it's i've never heard of
anyone that i know making millions off
of something oh good god
that's amazing wow are we rolling right
oh yeah
and welcome to the corridor cast guys oh
yeah hey interest what's up
my name is ren i'm peter my name is
clinton jones
i'm mo matt i'm a man i'm mad i'm not
mad i'm nervous
so before we go anywhere so we're going
to talk about harry potter rated r today
but first matt we haven't had a chance
to talk
on a date yesterday oh god we're going
to talk about this i just want to hear
i just wanted what happened so i didn't
go on valentine's day i went on
on saturday which is honestly the classy
day to go because
it's always busy yeah and also by the
way valentine's day first dates that's
like
i don't know
especially when it's like you got the
baggage of like oh yeah by the way
there's a lot riding on this moment here
between us so uh
also that that whole video was like
played up a little bit because i don't
i'm not really like looking for a
girlfriend yeah i mean you're a wife
you know um so you know it was like just
the casual thing
with someone that i i was talking to for
a while and okay yeah so
okay it wasn't like a it wasn't a big
deal but it was fun
did you have a good time yeah i did have
a good time did you know about it again
yes yeah because she saw she saw the
tinder profile oh okay
yeah the updated pimped tinder profile
she was like
oh upgrades oh yeah yeah do you have
those biceps in real life
no sorry it's all right why don't you
come find out yeah
i do have the water bottles though i
dropped the water bottles legit
did you show her like hey these are from
yeah pictures and i just tried to flex
as hard as i could
you're like hey you want to drink you
want a drink you just like burst through
your shirts like yeah
the weirdest part about that video
though was the amount of comments
and dms i got saying that i should
apply those pictures to grindr oh
hey maybe you should go to the other
side of the fence on this one
it's like wow i do find the find it
quite amusing though this like you got
like
these guys making you tender profile who
have never used tenders
yeah like a meta
aspect of the narrative before before we
get into harry potter because this
this podcast is going to be about the
harry potter rated rv effects we're
talking about
i want to ask you guys what's the most
awkward worst
date you've ever been on oh boy oh um
i wasn't an awkward date but it was an
awkward moment
when i was walking my dog one time a few
years ago i don't know i think i've told
you this story
so i'm walking my dog and these two uh
fairly attractive women are walking the
other direction from me and they come
walking by
and uh you know like i'm not afraid of
like making eye contact with strangers i
look at them i smile and as we're like
pretty much between like you and me
distance
uh i'll take my mask off to demonstrate
what happened
i hiccuped i just
had a random hiccup but it happened as i
was trying to breathe in
oh my god christian knows the story i've
told him this story
so i'm walking along and i just i'm
smiling at them and as i'm making that
contact eye contact i got
and i just like i was like i just kept
walking i was like don't look back
don't look back i was just like i made a
hundred and i was like
oh my god that's so funny dude i can
imagine like
how embarrassing that would be like in
the grand scheme of things not that bad
but that's still like
that like an embarrassing day no but i i
it was the only i didn't
i paused my audio book because i
couldn't focus on it and i was just
replaying that moment for the entire
like 15-minute walk around the block
and as soon as i was back in the
apartment i told jenna all about it i
was like i can't believe this just
happened
i can't believe that just happened what
it was like amazing five seconds go by
and you're just like
you're like that you're both walking
your opposite direction and you just
like
you look back and they're just like
what's going on true love
peter that's pretty embarrassing man i
don't think i have any weird date
stories they've all been either
normal or like super boring super
freaking hype dude yeah
usually it's i mean you usually try not
to set yourself up for bad dates right
it's like
you can kind of feel people out like say
you meet him in person
and like you kind of already know that
you have a vibe no i've had days where
it's like there just isn't a spark or
anything inside
like nothing's gonna happen here but
yeah nothing like horrible
here's hoping yeah how old were you
in 2010 i was 12 years old
that was when i started dating jenna oh
well
12 years old in 2010 let's see what yeah
i was 21. goodness oh my god
how old are you right now no uh peter
how old are you right now 11 really 23 i
think how do you matt that means
yeah i'm 26. it gets a little hazy in
the i would be a sophomore in high
school
in 2010. isn't dean the youngest
out of everyone i'm the youngest you are
[Laughter]
your skills aren't maxed they're just
really high thanks yeah
i've never seen you so high before
skills skills yeah skill high you know
yeah
when did you start working in 3d
programs uh when i was like
13 or something i was just i'm just a
super introverted person
and so my idea of a good time is like
hunkering down by myself as a hermit
dude
just like working on stuff and so that's
just what i did the whole time growing
up
how did you get extroverted extroverted
yeah or at least the
the facade of an extrovert well it's
just thing
like i definitely have a lot of social
anxiety but you know over the years you
learn how to make it look like you don't
okay you know um i have a whole theory
on on
uh introverted versus extrovert i don't
think one or the other actually exists
i think everyone is able to socialize to
different degrees of like skill in
general
but everyone has a social battery that
is a different capacity for every person
because you know people say that i'm
extroverted but i think i'm introverted
so why is that the case i think what it
comes down to is like
you know i have a good time hanging out
with people but eventually my battery
gets low enough that i'm like i
i'm done i don't want to see any more
people and everyone feels that way
yeah totally that makes sense but then
you have some people who like recharge
by hanging out with other people so it's
not like this is a really robust theory
i'm just saying
i feel like that's uh more uncommon than
not is the people who like recharge with
other people i
i hear very few people who are like that
yeah like uh when i was in college a lot
of my friends were theater students
and they are some of the most
introverted people around and yet they
are also some of the most social people
around
like they have very good social skills
and they can like hang out in a crowd
throw a really fun party but they all
self-identify as introverted
interesting so i think it's always a
matter of like how much
social interaction do you want before
you're like i'm i'm ready to be alone
and do whatever i like doing alone
mm-hmm yeah yeah i feel like i'm an
extroverted person
but like i also at the same time i would
i want to live alone like i don't want
to have roommates
i want to have like a limited like my
own space you know
yeah so like and when i go home i don't
want to like you know i don't always
want to go out and stuff so like
yeah i think it's it's a spectrum i just
think it's like the right roommates
though too because i really like
just quiet in silence i get enough noise
every day
and it's just life is just freaking like
non-stop
noise yeah and uh it's nice to go home
and definitely have like just silence
you know like when's the last time it's
been silent for 30 minutes
in a row definitely not today yeah or
like even on your drive home it's like
usually like i have music on
you know and it's like oh i should
probably just drive home in silence but
it's hard to
i do that sometimes sometimes it's like
i like to live in my head when i drive
and so like
yeah sometimes i'll get home and i'm
like i didn't even i didn't didn't even
remember to put anything on
it's like wow it's like we get so much
stimulus stimuli over the course of the
day it's like i
find myself always like i'm alone with
my thoughts for 10 seconds and i'm like
all right time to put on a podcast or
something it's like
i find myself having to carve out time
to just think
you know like like purposely not putting
anything on yeah at home
yeah yeah it's nice to have that time
like quiet place time
you asked the question oh oh yeah we
didn't forget about you buddy
what has been your most awkward date um
oh my god i mean dude i have i have
stories but
but they're too long
i
yeah and christian too is there a
consolidated version of that story
not really okay you gotta hype it up
tell me like
that the like the come back later
synopsis like how it started how it's
going
version of that i mean i know how it's
going okay so
like i i was really awkward
around women and like um
especially if they're attractive very
awkward like very awkward and i don't
really know
like like there's like a game going on
you know
or at least they probably think there's
a game but maybe there's a game
it might like it's confusing it's mind
games and like um
basically eli was trying to hook me up
with somebody uh some
anyone anyone eli at pax
in uh seattle and like oh i kept telling
him no
no i just want to enjoy myself and like
not have to be all stressed out every
night and every day
and um it was like five days you know
the whole time and like
he eventually you know i'm like you know
what maybe i should you know what maybe
i should
like just to prove to myself you know
like and i find someone
and like we start talking and then eli
just like it's like dude go for it like
put your hand on her back put your hand
on her back i'm like get out of here
stop it
and he's like he's just like egging me
on like constantly constantly
that's that's awful it was horrible dude
like i i can see how that because it's
like
especially if you feel like she could
hear him oh my god
yeah yeah yeah yeah and then there's a
lot of pressure and even if she can't
yeah just the fact that you're having to
worry did she hear him say
put my hand on his on her back and now
if i do it she's gonna be like you just
listen to him
and then now just like the circle
continues it was bad it was bad it's a
lot of pressure
and then but it ended it goes so far
dude
basically it ended up where i drove her
back to la and like hung out for a week
and then like then she started telling
me like
god spoke to me i need to be here with
you like i need to be here
and then i was like i bought her a plane
ticket to fly
back home and then she was like i'm not
getting on this plane
once and god spoke to me and i'm like
you better get on that plane like you're
gonna be homeless in l.a
and that was like the day we went to go
play airsoft together at hollywood
sports park
and i was like so happy to just be with
my friends because like i was
i was just consumed by her for like a
week and a half straight
oh my god yeah you know how long the
that's a 17 hour drive
i know yeah i've i've done the drive
many times it is a
very long drive that sounds so stressful
dude it was the worst it was the worst
week of my life
wait okay so were you like already like
i'm not into this girl by the time you
were driving down
you're like when did it hit you
before i even said yes oh man
yeah it was so bad it was so bad you
just couldn't say no
i could i couldn't i was too nice i was
too late she was crying in my passenger
seat just like crying dude
and so didn't she like stalk you for a
while too she came back to my house
she started dropping off all these gifts
did she fly so she you
she got on the airplane the ticket that
you bought for her she flew to hawaii
then she flew back from
where is that you drove to from hawaii
to l.a no no she
she flew back home she feels like home
across the u.s maybe i misheard you i
thought like you said you got her a
plane ticket
to her home in hawaii it was like it was
like the same distance but just didn't
completely mishear that dang yeah i
wouldn't be surprised but like yeah and
then she kept like sending me all these
gifts and stuff and painting me all
these paintings and like oh my god
all our lives are meant to be and like i
like started
tweeting like i'm your oh my boyfriend
you know
that and i'm just like what and then
someone hit me on twitter and it's like
yo you're this girl saying that she's
your girlfriend like owes me
money for a new car like she crashed my
car or something like that and like
dude is bad oh my god he's back like
that's not even that's the tip of the
iceberg
yeah seriously well i'm sorry that's
like the worst case scenario oh it's
it was so bad and then dude and then we
found out
that she started doing this she did this
to someone else
when i was working at rocket jump at the
time like
we were working with uh um uh
the nerdist the company the nerd is like
right over and like
this guy was like oh dude she got you
two huh what
and i was like oh man what are you
leaving me too
she did the same thing to me and he was
like shell shocked and all this i was
like what
what the heck dude it was crazy it was
crazy it was like a crazy
um crazy week man she just like followed
me everywhere
oh god that sounds super stressful so
harry potter rated r huh
yeah jesus dang man that's i mean
how long ago was that was that like five
years ago that was
no no no it was more than that it was
like seven okay that was like pax 20
something jimmy was there dee was there
eli was there
everyone was there oh my god it's a good
time
that may have been the same packs where
uh dee met my cousin
maybe me and me dee and jimmy went to
pax for like four years in a row
together what is that like a music
festival or something penny arcade expo
it's a
it's a gaming convention made by gamers
for gamers
sounds awesome it's the best well yeah
it's the best pax prime in seattle so
it's like e3 but not shitty
yeah it's like e3 but smaller and cooler
and like more accessible and more fun
and less corporate and just like sounds
great it's sick dude
yeah and it's in it's in downtown
seattle so it's like that's cool
you got uh pike street right there and
it's just amazing
that was wonderful dude out of the blue
one day when you guys are at pax
like i get a text from uh from dee
and it's this image with him and my
cousin
and i'm just like i don't know if you
got this but like
it it is so out of the blue because they
apparently just randomly hanging out and
started talking about like
oh yeah like d saying like oh yeah i
live down the lane arthur is his name
he's like oh yeah my cousin moved to l.a
uh he does like like youtube stuff too
he's like oh yeah what's his name his
name is ren and he's just like
you're kidding me this is at the time
when dee and i sat
next to each other up in studio three
yeah like uh
because you sat there for a while too
against the wall next to the stairwell
because he was editing note and i was
doing behind the scenes for the sam nico
channel
and we literally sat next to each other
that's insane
dude that small world stuff like small
old stories are so crazy yeah
wild so that's that's my biggest
takeaway from pax having never been
nice i should go someday i'm i'm looking
forward to reintegrating into society
someday
it's gonna be so nice i wanna go to nab
i wanna go to concerts and maybe i think
it's probably gonna be our big
thing for the company at least is uh
yeah i mean i i have a feeling once like
there's enough of a rollout
for vaccines where people can reliably
and trustedly say like all right
i'm vaccinated no one will get you know
i think there are going to be so many
parties
everyone's going to it's going to be
their own in history as like the year
when everyone went bashing crazy
i'm honestly ready for it too i'm ready
for all the parties yeah we gotta we
gotta get to that point that's the only
thing you said at concerts man like i
want to go to concerts
so bad christian yep dying dying to go
yeah absolutely and we spawn i wanna go
we spell so
yes in a year
you just waited you're just like caked
in a layer of the entire
the 2020 cake candle wax yeah i have a
i have a story all right um
now she's okay with me telling the story
okay see she's cool she's cool
this is the first date okay and we i
took her to
like this this wine place right um and
she had mentioned
kind of kind of briefly that she didn't
really drink too much but she likes
to drink a glass of wine or whatever
sure but so we were sitting down and
talking and she seemed kind of nervous
um like the whole time she seemed just a
little bit nervous to
just go on a date in general um and
and so we had a bottle of wine i had
like a glass
and a half maybe and i didn't realize it
but she had kind of like finished the
bottle
by the time i finished the tape yeah
but she didn't like she wasn't like
acting super drunk right yeah
um so so that
by the end of the night i'm like we
let's go to in and out you know we'll
just have like a little interesting and
then
and then we'll oh so good i'll take you
back or whatever right
um and so so we drive over to in and out
um
and as soon as we pull in she's in my
passenger seat
and she just leans over and vomits all
over
the interior of my car oh man and i'm
just like sitting there
like i don't know what to do i was just
like shell shocked for a second
how old were you uh this was like three
years ago okay
yeah and i'm just like uh
like on you or just no just just like
like on the ground
oh god just vomit all over the place and
i'm like
oh no and i was trying to be super nice
about it and just like
uh um i think should we is this
like really embarrassing and just like i
i i'm gonna i have to go back
oh man you just continue ordering in and
out and
yeah like well i mean we're here
yeah it kind of ruined the idea of in
and out for me
they're dipping sauces so i just like
called that's mostly calder and uber
yeah that's probably when chris was like
just like it was late
so i was like i couldn't even get my car
detailed so i had to
just like get paper towels
clean it in the morning in the morning i
mean yeah i did the paper towel thing
but like
dude that was that's about like from
zero to 60
as bad as it can get in one night that's
right yeah
did you see her again after that uh no
no oh it kind of kind of we both sort of
mutually were like okay
we're in the mood maybe this wasn't
wasn't for us
yeah wow well that's a low point for us
in the podcast guys it's your boy brandi
o'daniel here back for another episode
with today's sponsor
brilliant.org now if you guys don't know
brilliant
is an app and website where you learn
fundamental concepts
of math science and computer science and
all the laws
that shape our world you learn
interactively
you don't just take formulas and then
write them down
and then apply them and then not really
understand why you're applying them like
you probably did in school all the time
i know i did it that's how i got through
a lot of courses the problem is
i never remembered any of it and so with
brilliant you can actually have fun
learning through the little scenarios
and interactive experiences that they
give you on the site now one of my
favorite courses
is probability fundamentals now
obviously
i took economics in college that was
great i took econometrics in college
that was
well that course was pretty rough but
the point is with probability
fundamentals i did not feel like how i
felt in econometrics so if you guys are
interested head on over to brilliant.org
corridor cast and you can get 20
off a premium membership if you're one
of the first 200 people to sign up using
that url
um and also you can sign up and get
started for free
let's get back to the podcast i think
it's time to talk about harry potter
yeah
how long has it been in this podcast so
far we still haven't talked about the
headlining story
okay so matt you started off we actually
had this idea to do harry potter radar
weeks ago
yeah so it's your responsibility to comb
through every single frame of
every movie to find every potential
scene i i don't know did you actually
look through all the movies i did yeah
i i did a deep dive not as deep as clint
cause he watched all the movies
for vfx artists react for vfxr but
yeah like so i didn't watch all the
movies i've seen all the movies at one
point but you scrubbed
i scrubbed i got like a good sense of
because uh
you you have some good scenes that are
like made rated are just because of the
editing like cutting to the right
uh reaction the right context being cut
away or something
it's always the best yeah yeah mad-eyed
moody has a scene
where he's where all of he basically
turns everyone into harry potter and
then makes him disrobe
he has a line where he says you're
underage harry
oh no yeah that's a crazy scene just
on its own it is yeah if you tweak the
the lines a little bit and
cut it different it makes it super weird
absolutely dude yeah that's gonna make
it really creepy
but like your um your after effects
skills are really nice dude
like thank you what's the kid in with
the camera in uh
in two in the championship oh calling
creepy yeah i had to look up what his
name was because
i didn't know that i know a lot about
harry potter i don't know how you know
that i had to look it up
about harry potter lore i can't believe
you knew that wow but you took his head
off
i took his head clean off because
there's a scene in the yeah the second
movie
in the in the quidditch match uh where
harry
and uh and malfoy are like chasing the
snitch
and you know they go through the map and
everything right and
they fly past this little camera boy and
the bludger ball that's
that's chasing them flies directly over
him
and he narrowly avoids it so basically i
just
i just like froze him his body so that
he doesn't duck
and then gets his head just clean taken
off it's beautiful i've seen it it's
it's gorgeous i've been killing it with
these after effects it's so much fun man
i love doing it yeah
doing that stuff but you like go to the
next level where you're like
you know uh isolating their robes
and then animating their robes yeah be
all like blowing in the wind
and it's like all that stuff is like
super simple 2d comps it's just like you
you think about how robes are supposed
to behave and how cloth is supposed to
move
and you just isolate the robe cloth and
and
uh those layers and puppet tool them and
just do a little wiggle
yeah just just wiggle certain points um
yeah with the wiggle expression and dude
it's like
it really sells it it does it works
really well you can really sell them
yeah cause it's like for the show where
you were you're just like oh yeah i just
i just froze him before he
ducked and was like that simple phrase
like we get it we understand what you
mean but it's like what you did i assume
because it's
a tracking shot right yeah so you had to
like 2d track it and take a freeze frame
of that whole bit
of him all right did you do a frame just
around him or like a big
soft frame around it no no i did a just
an uh uh
you know a roto on him okay on his
silhouette you painted it
but then you'd have to paint them out
and then i painted them out yeah i had
to paint out yeah the background layer
and then i animated his body so that it
had some movement too that's right yeah
and then so the picture goes through and
then you cut back to the shot
yeah oh yeah as he falls down
there's a whole yearbook scene which i
don't want to elaborate on i want you to
see it in the video
because technically this is going to
come out before harry potter rated r
yeah but most people watching this will
probably come to this
after they see that video so they
already you already know what's up
yeah yeah but there's a shot that it
cuts back to where it says decapitated
body
you know just as he falls down and if
you and if you 2d animate
a still image you have to give it
movement back
right you can't just freaking make it
fall uh without like
bending the body and making it do things
that you know
a body in articulation would would do
you're simulating ragdoll but in 2d
yeah exactly yeah and manually you're
not even simulating it sure i'm just
yeah i'm just manually animating
with the puppet tool yeah
yeah yeah yeah did you uh adjust the
curves and stuff like that oh yeah of
course
curves adjustments are where it's at
like if you can master like
how curves work
dude the graph editor is so crucial for
animation
yeah it's very important dude talking
about manual keyframes
i was looking over on peter's computer
and i saw
like harry being lifted into the air and
like
start shaking and then his bones started
snapping and folding in and like then he
turned and
turned into a ball like that was
incredible
thanks yeah i mean it's only like half
keyframed because
my favorite thing about blender and i'm
sure cinema can do this too is that you
can add like procedural noise
for movement so you can just like on the
these axes of the elbow like
tell it to move this much per frame or
whatever and it just wiggles it like the
wiggle expression
after effects exactly and so you can do
like animations for people where they're
kind of moving like this
and you get a little bit of swaying and
stuff so it feels natural
but it's 100 procedural and then you
just animate on top of that
you know so we got all like the snaps
and bends and brakes but then all the
shaking is just like that's
underneath it super nice and convenient
it looks really good
thanks and really brutal um
yeah i guess do you want to talk about
yeah what you're doing i mean i don't
even know
how this came about i just because we
were going to do harry potter rated art
and it's like
you know the first thing you think of is
like somebody shoots somebody with a
wand and they explode with blood and
it's like
that's awesome but after so many that
just gets boring and you know you gotta
this whole idea is honestly just an
excuse for us to just do some cool
effects that don't really have any
grounding in reality just
an excuse to do them and with like the
broad
sort of basis of like oh it's rated r
because that's like the clickable thing
right but
i'm sure you started forgot about rated
r you're like let's play some basketball
it gets gory and so now you've made it
even more than it would have been
retroactively made it yeah tell
everybody like
what the scene is because no one knows
so yeah there's this dueling scene in
the second harry potter movie where it's
like harry and malfoy on this little
table dueling it out or whatever and uh
the table is huge
oh yeah it's it's a big old table yeah
and a great hall table
the feasting table oh is that what that
is
interesting anyways yeah they're like
fighting in so in my version malfoy
shoots a spell
and it like misses harry by a hair and
it goes behind him and it like hits the
floor and it's like something starts
rising up out of the floor
and then it explodes in like a
basketball hoop it's like
and um yeah harry like turns around to
see the basketball hoof which is still
raising him and then he like
turns back around and before he can do
anything malfoy hits him with another
spell
and he just like goes up into the air
like like that
it's kind of reminiscent of that other
scene in harry potter with that girl
yeah like i know the show you're talking
about yeah because that had like one of
the creepiest like
that's terrifying because she goes up
and she starts with that high-pitched
scream and then it cuts in on her face
like and she's like ah
well her hair's in the air and they put
it in an underwater tank oh really
oh yeah cool that's so cool yeah that
was terrifying
wow but it's very much like that where
it's like you get hoisted up and you
just get possessed
yeah that was that was the sixth movie i
believe yeah
yeah because they filmed a lot of
underwater stuff for the fourth movie
for goblet of fire
right um and then that was when they
learned about deathly hallows and stuff
yeah but yeah so he gets possessed and
his bones
start like breaking in different ways
and then he curls up into a little
basketball that like splats down on the
floor then
draco like runs and does like rand
freaking helped me record some motion
capture it was so good he like
freaking went percent on it and it's
like office b-baller
yeah no i like i put on the coco suit
and he's like all right now
dunk harry potter cool
i and i didn't know that you had so so
much like basketball skill
did i played basketball all through high
school yeah i wouldn't say i was like
very good but at the school i was out i
was
one of the better players i got the mvp
my senior year oh my goodness could you
like could you
have you ever shot a three before have i
ever shot a three
like a three-pointer have you yeah i've
tried three players
i've made three pointers before have you
ever dunked on the haters i've never
okay i've never dunked in the middle of
a game before and i never got to a point
where i can actually dunk a full-on
basketball but i got to a point where i
could dunk a women's basketball which
meant i was like just an inch shy from
being able to do it okay
wait what's the difference between a
woman's women's ball is smaller you mean
like the physical basketball or you mean
like the the
yeah the hoops are the same size oh so
you could palm it yeah
but let me know that wasn't the thing
the ball is smaller
so i was able to get it over the rim and
dunk it oh yeah i see it
men's basketball is slightly bigger and
so in order to like
you have to get an extra inch of
elevation to get it to clear the rim to
get it on
and and volleyballs are easy i could i
could dunk a volleyball pretty
consistently
interesting um i was able to get my hand
like this high above the rim yeah at my
peak
i've always wanted to like do a video
where it's like all right i train so i
can slam dunk a basketball but that's
like we're talking like six months of
yeah have you ever broken the backboard
like shattered the glass
no that's really hard to do is that
possible it was back in the day
until shaq kept doing it and so they had
to like redesign all the backboards to
not
do that really yeah jeez you gotta like
play in an intramural league and then
get some stunt people we know to go in
and set charges
in the back of the basketball thing so
you do it
so yeah granted i played i played high
school basketball in asia so it was like
i had a height advantage
oh man in vietnam yeah
that's crazy it wasn't at an
international school so there are a lot
of non-asian people there too
for sure but still nice but yes thanks
for helping me with that uh mocap
yeah this is like all right if i'm like
up on stage in front of a bunch of
people what would i do it's like all
right
i'm gonna showboat a little bit like
dribble between the legs and then like
did you
did you use a real basketball or is it
just mine we well okay
we used to have a basketball i couldn't
find it so we used like a little bouncy
ball like a toy store like bouncy ball
that's like this big
okay um it the bouncing dynamics were so
weird on it i couldn't like
dependently like use it so we opted to
not have any ball and i would just go
through the motions
yeah which is proven to be a bit
difficult because it's i don't know
where to put the basketball because
it's just like going like this and i'm
like what do i do with this
how do i animate harry dude he's gonna
make it like janky
with the shot the shot where i go and
like i pick up because
you can do this thing where you you slap
the ball and you curl your fingers
around
and that that curling along with the
slap causes the ball to rise up into
your hand
it's a pretty common thing you just like
get the ball up into the air yeah and it
looks it works so well
for harry it's like well yeah thanks for
like telling me that i wouldn't have
done that otherwise
but like the way you have the camera
like push in so that like i do that then
i
the first dribble is like right on top
of the camera
yeah dude so that's what i'm working on
now is just the dribbling thing and it's
been the most challenging
just like because i'm also trying to get
like the squash and stretch thing you
know with animation yeah if you're like
like the first thing you do in animation
class is you do like the ball like
when it's going down it's elongated and
when it hits the ground it like
squeezes pancake pancake right right
so i'm trying to do that and it's a bit
challenging but i'm really excited for
the sequence
it's looking really good so far i'm the
most excited for that dude i'm excited
for your lego harry potter
yeah yeah that's done dude oh that was
the other thing i was just like
because i i kind of came on to this
project late because i was doing other
things and i was just like is this rated
r harry potter like
is it though because i turn around and
he's like modeling a basketball hoop
coming out of the ground and you're like
legos
lego harry potter like this is rated art
and i'm over here looking at decapitated
heads
i got some of it like you guys you guys
you guys kind of scared me because i was
like dang lego harry potter that'd be so
funny
and matt was like dude that's so funny i
was like yeah i'm doing that and then
like nick comes over he's like
what what i thought this was supposed to
be rated r
and then you said the same thing and
then like nico comes up and just looks
at my computer and just like what are
you working on and i'm like
harry potter lego harry potter he's like
oh and then he like just walks away
oh yeah of course so then i'm like god
damn is it bloody enough
is it gory enough and like you know
trust his head comes off and like
he shoots blood from his head and falls
over but it's all legos
lego brick blood so it's kind of the pg
version i mean it's a great gag
but yeah i think so too totally worth it
i think it's hilarious and that's partly
why i think it deserves to like
you know be a thing because it's like
the whole rated r thing is just it's
just an
excuse to make a video about harry
potter yeah yeah it just makes me laugh
i think it's super funny that he turns
into a yeah
it's hilarious so so like we have all
these crazy
ideas and stuff that we're talking about
here but like how do we
like get to that point because i don't
think we talked about that as much like
like what is that that process is like a
lot of fun
for me the brainstorming yeah so like
maybe we should talk about that a little
bit
because like yeah we have to look at a
bunch of clips
right and just kind of like bounce ideas
around
but like what you know well isn't it
generally just like all right we just
kind of like
because you you supplied all these clips
you're like here's some good
potential things that could be done with
right and we just kind of watch and it's
just like we just start throwing out
ideas and like the ideas that get the
most laughs are the ones that were like
oh that has something to it okay
it's kind of like kids after school
hanging out and just like shooting the
[ __ ]
watching movies going like hey that
would be really funny if he did this
yeah yeah yeah it feels a lot like that
it definitely does but then we're doing
it you know
yeah yeah um because you got to write
that line between like oh that's
hilarious i have no idea how to do that
yeah exactly
yeah there's also that there's that sort
of like assessment where it's like okay
yeah this is everybody's laughing at
this idea but can we actually access it
like what if harry potter opens the door
and it's just a part of the hell and
then a dragon comes out and starts like
ripping him apart and he's like really
dragging huh
yeah ripping him apart okay uh yeah okay
how are we going to do that i'm kind of
in that boat right now with my spike
wall shot oh really
it's getting grief a little bit i'm kind
of worried about it because like
basically it's the same scene that
peter's working on
with like the wizard duel on the table
and like
you know there's three wizards that go
up so there's three moments and i'm
doing the one with like
the fancy showboat professor what's his
name
yeah yeah he gets like zapped and gets
flown into a spike wall
and there's like all these skeletons
hanging from the spike wall like he's
just another one of the freaking
guys um i built out the scene and i got
the skeletons like hanging i still need
to like
adjust them and make them a bit more
random but i'm stuck where i'm trying to
figure out like
was weird oh
wow buddy i'm chilling i'm just talking
too fast
um i'm stuck at a point where
i need to get a 3d model of lockhart
that looks good enough
and have him ragdoll into this wall and
i don't know how to do ragdolls
really in c4d well it's because there's
not really a way to do it
you can do like the whole like soft body
cage system
but it's like it's still not really
right i mean there's the chris schmidt
method
where you use connectors and
you rig up the bones
but that's just such a process he's got
a tutorial on it which i'll probably
follow for this but
you mean where you do like constraints
between the bones and you set like a
rigid body object yeah
yeah i mean i think that's what ragdolls
like any ragdoll software is doing you
just have to do it manually it's the
same thing in blender
for sure how do you do in blender is it
literally the same way you just make
like a rough
yeah like a rough rigid body object for
each like segment of the body
and then connect them with like
constraints it's a pain in the ass but
it works
so this guy hit me up on twitter he's
making a uh
a plug-in for c4d called body solver oh
man
uh it's like an automatic ragdoll
simulator oh my god
that's amazing um
wait is this the guy who makes
the have you seen those videos on
instagram or twitter
of like people like ghosting up a wall
like the ragdoll
thing ghosting up the wall similar to
that i know you're talking about that
what's his name um he does all those
like cool ragdolls yeah
no it's not that it's similar he's he's
making it uh
uh but yeah anyway he so i checked out
his profile he's he's like i guess
making this thing but it's gonna be like
a proper like ragdoll thing for c4d but
no idea when that's going to come out
that's cool
because it's strange that there's not
like a proper ragdoll workflow
inside of cinema 4d or any 3d software
or at least c40 and blender because that
was like one of the earlier things like
it was in 3ds max and there's that one i
forget the name of the program that we
used for
uh uh the half-life
movie that we did and five years ago um
the half-life house was a real gravity
gun yeah really good video
it was it was an actual dedicated
ragdoll program
within 3ds max no no it was its own
problem and then you would like export a
sequence
yeah yeah sam and nico used it a bunch
for pretty much every time they did a
ragdoll like remember heart of the insta
kill
yeah yeah so would you just like build
out the geometry in 3ds max export it to
your program with your camera track
you do the simulation in that program
and then you just re-import
yeah interesting that's that sounds
great where's the program what is that
it i forget the name of it i forget the
name of it it was a long time ago
man it was like not really that
supported at a certain point anymore it
was like
dude you know what would be crazy is if
uh the ambergen guys did like
body gen or like and you just import
your mesh and then you just
you know that would be amazing that'd be
sick
that's your dilemma right that's where
i'm stuck right now basically just the
ragdoll
the ragdoll is like a long tedious
manual process that i can kind of see
the light at the end of the tunnel but
getting the lockhart model looking nice
is a problem for me like i'm gonna i
don't know
i mean you could cover it up with like
blood and guts you know you just have a
motion blur into frame and then he hits
the thing and it's like you cover up all
the parts that look bad with your guts
that's what i've been doing with my 2d
columns right
it's like this looks a little janky in
the road it's a little chunk them up
blood
i have but here's the issue i'm i'm out
tomorrow and i'm
only in on wednesday so i have to do all
i have to comp the lego shot
i have and i have to figure out all
these issues on wednesday and
finish it and render it and deliver it
and film with nick
on how to like how did i do it okay but
do you need to do ragdolls could you
just keyframe
the stuff
yeah dive into those curves curves
honestly
that'd probably be faster yeah
i mean i mean honestly i think just if
you if you make a cage
no screw the cage screw the freaking
rigid bodies
i'm gonna just manually do it yeah it's
actually like a shot like that is
it was totally gonna work for that
because it's so fast it's such a fast
movement as he's like blowing back into
the wall
yeah he's like boom yeah he cracks his
head and he goes
swivels yeah and then that's it you
don't even need to animate the whole
body you just need to
do the limbs yeah yeah
okay but like i i hear you you're like i
don't have enough time
to figure out all these problems that i
i
foresee to like figure out how to do
this and
also do the shot because the shot that i
decided to do is
uh in the first movie when uh the
the trio decided to sneak out late at
night this towards the end
or two thirds of the way through the
first movie neville finally grows the
bone
or grows above gross
[Laughter]
that's the phrase now that's the phrase
now grow a bone bro
yeah he stands up to them and he's like
i'll fight you if i need to and and
hermione's like you're stupid and
uh petra petrified him or not petrifie
petrificus
yeah anyway he falls down and honestly
i've watched this shot so many times now
i can't figure out what is going on
because this kid falls over like a board
super stiff
i brought that up i brought that clip up
um to lauren
on the uh stuntman react did you guys
react to it yeah
really she thinks it's a stunt person
just doing it but like a
purse like an adult person dressed in
the same either there's an adult or a
woman
yeah that has that shape okay yeah who's
smaller and like yeah
a pad under the ground or something
because also the the perspective of it
makes it so that
uh because that person's so much closer
to camera anyway
you can't really tell the height because
they he towers over
the other three just but not because he
he appears taller it's just because
perspective the perspective yeah
i mean so he appears taller but in a way
that we subconsciously interpret as he's
closer rather than taller yeah
maybe it was a little forced perspective
kind of thing but the the stun
is crazy because it's like it if for
from hot moment there i thought maybe he
was just a doll
but you can tell like when when he lands
his hands kind of shoot outwards but
immediately go back to his yeah
his uh his arms against his side wow
that's a
crazy stunt if they did that for real
his head
hits the ground like his head straight
up hits the ground his entire body
lifts an inch or two off the ground oh
my god like
i forget who suggested this but it could
have been somebody wearing a
full mask with a pad in the back of the
head that's true i think there's a i
think there's a pad underneath the
carpet
yeah so there's a big rug that they're
on and i think they probably just made
it pretty soft
uh impact soft so it's like it won't
like deform like you're
standing on like a cushion you know but
uh
uh soft enough that it won't it's not
like you're landing on on wood or stone
lauren said there was air pads that
people use
like gymnasts will like do their round
off tuck
freaking backflips off of a really blown
up air pad
so it's it's sturdy you can walk on it
you can bounce on it you can
jump into it and it'll it'll give you a
little bit of bounce uh-huh
so it could have been that too
interesting okay dang
you guys just reacted to that this
morning cool it's gonna be in a video
that's awesome
great yeah cause i would love to hear
more about that anyway dude regardless
of pads regardless of error
whatevers yeah that's like that's one of
those like a trust fall you know when
you do trust falls
and it's like you have every instinct to
like you first of all you have to trust
the other person to catch you but yeah
everything in your brain tells you that
you have to like react to this this like
movement you know because it's very hard
you have to catch yourself so like these
stunt people have to like just
stay stiff stiff as a board and fall all
the way back
full send full sense dude i kind of want
to try intense on the pad
out here after this yeah on the pad on
the pod right now
i mean i don't know hitting your head
like that sucks
you got to tuck it like i basically did
the the equivalent of that
on my front where i just did the truss
fall flat and hit
and i had a headache for like a really
bad splitting headache for a solid five
minutes
yeah well dude that's crazy man
yeah so the the idea of the shot yeah is
he falls down and shatters
because uh like hermione freezes him or
whatever and like so he falls down and
the original
idea is that like the outer his skin and
clothes
froze solid and when he hits the ground
it all breaks
and the inside of his body like pours
out blood just like a whole like liquid
simulation of blood pouring out
and his bones like floating in the blood
floating away
as it just goes out across the ground i
was like that would be brutal
and i think if i had more time i could
figure out how to do that because
i think i can do it with x particles
which is a really cool simulation
plug-in within cinema 4d it does a whole
lot of stuff including you know liquids
although i don't think it does liquids
like super well because it's the meshing
aspect that i think it
like you have to have a really good
measure and having not actually
experimented with it i can't say for
certain
it's got some good measures okay good
yeah but yeah and i was like you know
what
i only have like a day to do this shot
so i don't know if i
can do that so i decided to abandon the
blood idea so instead it's just gonna be
like an eggshell cracking
him breaking open which i just
experimented so i just recently learned
how to do that like last week
and uh and then it's just like a
skeleton is revealed oh no that's great
yeah so it's like it's still i mean
maybe i'll have like some like blood
elements like through compositing like
splat on the ground like
but it won't be an actual liquid sim you
just need to texture the skeleton
to like chunky blood like it's got to be
like blood-coated skeleton
yeah that makes sense
guts just because i'm afraid that it
like if i do go
down that road i haven't actually
finished the shot yet so i haven't
gotten to that point of texturing the
bones but
i worry that maybe it won't look like
bones anymore yeah
that's my concern what is this
just put meat in the joints
he suggested the same things like you
can already do soft bodies throw a bunch
of organs in there like throw some
organs in there
yeah what do you mean just download some
freaking yeah that's a lot more work
go on the oregon trail and download some
more remodels
is that the website i guess it is now
i'm
buying that domain yeah that's a great
one yeah uh and
but like what makes that shot is the
casualness of
harry potter and ron and hermione
because they're just like
like ron's like you're scary you know
that and she's like
then they they're harry's like let's go
and then they walk over him and then
ron's
like sorry neville it's for your own
good jeez dude
and it's like so there's three shots one
where he gets frozen one where he falls
down and one when they walk over him so
and you got time to do it all right
we'll see yeah i'm gonna try
mm-hmm are you hitting that moment of
like do i want to
hunker down and spend all this time on
this thing and have it be really
difficult or do i want to like cut out
some stuff
and have it be fine well i'm working on
the main key shot first or the the the
hero shot which is like him shattering
that's like the main one
but i have to like figure out projection
mapping for the texture on him
first which wait did the model i'd give
you my work well it's it's
i gotta get the projection from him on
the ground there oh right
uh because that that's where he's
actually gonna shatter um
that what what you put on there totally
works for the rest of the body
so i think that'll totally work if you
want
we'll see we'll see we can talk we can
talk yeah like uh
i don't know we'll get it done now that
we're not shooting son of a dungeon on
wednesday
i think i'll have a little bit more time
nice oh yeah
how much snow did you guys get you
listeners because apparently the whole
country got
1800 feet of snow wow
wow california yeah except for
california we just had a little bit of
wind
so by a little we actually had a lot of
wind this weekend there's a lot of winds
you see we didn't get snow
we have a lot of snow yeah oh geez it
was like stacked oh my god
like it's friggin imagine that wait
which must be so freezing oh ian yeah no
my parents too
they got like uh 16 inches of snow yeah
it's like the whole my parents whole
property there and like because
they live like literally three miles
from ian hubert yeah
yeah we visited him and then we had him
over at my parents place for dinner yeah
that was awesome that was amazing man
but yeah so yeah the whole northwest got
hit with a whole bunch of snow and it
was like this whole v
shape going down through uh like nevada
and colorado to texas so texas got hit
with a lot of snow and
ice cold temperatures and then a v shape
going back up to the
northeast and i was like why is it that
v shape and it's because that's the
actual
it's not a v it's the outer circle of
the polar vortex
hold on what huh i said um like i
understood what you
meant but i don't know the polar vortex
is like basically all the cold air over
like the north pole essentially and
every year it kind of like shifts
downwards a little bit and every now and
then you got a big
swath i don't i don't know much about
weather dynamics but it's it's kind of
roughly basically
all the cold air from up north came
south and brought with it a whole bunch
of
cold cold yeah wow and by the way jake's
not on the podcast today
because his pipes are frozen solid oh
and
that's why i brought this up is because
he was supposed to arrive
yesterday because we're shooting son of
a dungeon this week wednesday and friday
because we shot a week ago wednesday and
friday so we've already filmed the first
half of son of a dungeon which is a
website exclusive show of us playing
dungeons and dragons
super cool check it out
quarterdigital.com and so he was
supposed to show up yesterday but
texas got overwhelmed by freezing
temperatures and snow and bad weather
and so they cancelled all the flights
he's like all right fine
we try to get a flight for like today or
tomorrow that flight also ended up
getting canceled so he got a flight for
wednesday morning at nine mm-hmm he's
gonna come in
literally come from the airport to here
just in time to start rolling
yeah and then we just learned about like
an hour or two ago that that flight also
got canceled oh no
that's honestly like i you know son of a
dungeon too bad
but thank god because i still need to do
i got some
work to do on my shots oh boy so this is
going to mean i can actually get those
shots yeah no same person
i'm in the exact same boat i'm like okay
this is not that bad yeah i have to
like you know dungeon but like thank god
i can
but now i'm concerned about our other
shoot which i can't really talk about
just yet but we're flying out to texas
next week oh yeah we're super excited
we're flying out i guess we'll see
we uh there's a company that makes a
product that we got ahead of time and
we're making a cool
really cool video and we're gonna put it
on something very very cool
i don't think anyone's ever done this
you're going to put the video on
something sick
yeah we're going to put it on freaking
quibby dude
maybe are you going to put the product
on something we're going to attach the
camera it's a camera camera there's a
new camera we're gonna put a camera on
something cool
and that's what we do uh yeah like
like an ipad for that stuff an iphone on
a tank kind of like
you put an iphone on a tank oh yeah
brother yes that's texas for you yep or
so anyway
is it is it a flip phone on a bowling
ball
if you if you follow a quarter digital
on twitter you probably already have an
idea
but i don't want to say anything more
about it right now uh
yeah and so that's supposed to be next
week we're supposed to fly out next
monday or tuesday shoot that's usually
wednesday yeah
and it might it might still be too cold
it might still be too snowy
i hope not i'm really excited for that
me too i hope that
it's one of the coolest ideas i i think
we've had in a while yeah
dude some snow might be cool for the it
might be it might be but it also makes
the whole i it makes it very featureless
and for the shots that we kind of are
hoping to get just
featureless as in is just white yeah oh
okay no go to a forest
get some trees it's not exactly an
option
you know you might be able to see
certain things in the snow
better likes like color like
yeah certain objects that you might want
to
track for certain things we'll see
they like with it with the temperature
and cold
we might not even be able to utilize
what we're going there for
the time you know yeah the tank the tank
might not like the cold and maybe they
don't want the tank to be out in the
cold
yeah you know it's like if it was gonna
be rainy we can't let the tank out in
the rain
yeah that was already one of our things
so that's why we're plotting out a few
days there in case it does rain for two
of the three days that we can film on
you know the other day so yeah this is
all still kind of up in the air
about that but dude you're gonna get
messages
you're gonna get messages
they still don't get it it's fine like
where did that tank video ever come out
the what that's what you're going to be
you're going to be getting messages
hey whatever happened to that tank video
dude my favorite thing that was
suggested was gopro on a date
yeah it's like the same format i should
have done that last weekend
i should have just put a strap that goes
to whatever explain it you just got one
right here
that's so funny don't talk about it how
awkward would that be she asked and you
just like
what are you talking about that's so
rude yeah excuse me
what are you talking about no you said
you just say i'm a tuber i'm a tuber
i'm a freaking tuber dude no i'm
influencing okay
don't ask questions i'm in the way i'm
influencing i'm busy live streaming
right now
no no all of your all of your tinder
pictures have to have you with the gopro
on your head yeah
so it's so it's justified normalized
and they're like oh this is interesting
what's this guys gopros it would be
weird if i didn't come to the date with
the gopro
yeah that's so goofy that's ridiculous
we that was the concept that we were
bouncing around on node two was that
right
we'd take it would be like a dating game
and they'd take me out
on like this these dates with random
like craigslist girls or something oh my
god
and they'd like feed lines to me in my
ear oh boy
that sounds horrible i would i'm so
stressed i would enjoy it
because i guess i i like the that kind
of pressure
it's like funny for me like i i we
like back in the day when i was a kid i
would do these things
where we would just like mess with
people in public kind of like eric andre
style yeah and we'd film it so
look at this i love that stuff it's a
prank bro yeah just a prank bro oh man i
can't i don't
i don't have the guts to do that stuff
yeah i like it
i like it a lot i've tried to film
something like that before but i just
feel too
uh uh cruel yeah to the person
yeah you don't want to be cruel to
people it's really just about like
creating uncomfortable situations
that's what's funny you don't want to be
like mean to people yeah
but even if it's just like you're
playing a joke on somebody like i still
feel really bad and i need to like i
can't do it
that's why it's gotta be like a
self-deprecating yeah it's like you walk
around like in your underwear covered in
slime it's like hot prank bro
that's what's great about eric andre is
he just like walks around new york
bloody like with a parachute dragging
behind yeah
it's like he's the joke yeah it's
hilarious i told you guys how jan has
eric andre blackmail right oh yeah i
wouldn't exactly call it blackmail
i know but huh but yeah don't worry
about it i'll tell you guys later
he worked with eric andre one time and
got some video files that he keeps on a
hard drive
anytime he gives it to anyone he's like
oh yeah don't look at the eric andre
blackmail by the way
dude i wonder meanwhile it's it's an
empty hard drive with one folder labeled
eric andre blackmail oh my god it keeps
it locked in a vault
yeah and it's actually like it actually
is legit
except for derek andre so he just
doesn't care oh okay like he's aware
he's in on it
it's just one of those things that's
funny yeah apparently jan worked with
eric for
quite some time a while back wow
yeah okay shots is there any there's
run you're just doing the one right yeah
i mean it's like three shots in one
scene
if i can make the scene work but i i
wish we could have done more shots from
later in the film because we've all kind
of just taken
scenes from the first two movies well
the thing with that is that the first
two movies are the most
innocent and that's the most exactly
that's to ruin
yeah because yeah movies are already
pretty dark right yeah for sure yeah and
violent and people die
more yeah yeah they don't play quidditch
anymore you know yeah they don't play
it for real ones are guns now
oh and that's i mean i feel like we have
to at least
mention the awesome video that this one
dude did a while back called harry
potter with guns
yeah yeah because he did he not only did
he
not only did he do a trailer of the
movie he did the entire
first movie every time a one gets
whipped out there's a gun
oh yeah man and it was like a full thing
he put a lot of work into this
wait what about the wand shop yeah
like literally just like shooting a gun
off and like every time you shoot a
spell and it would explode it'd be a
bullet hit
that's actually why i didn't use like
one shop stuff there i made sure to
watch that video because i didn't want
to
like retread on jokes that he's already
made
and you know i wanted the stuff that we
did to be pretty original
um so yeah i wanted to make sure that
none of that stuff
like he yeah he put guns in their hands
but he also made it violent too
yeah that's kind of like his marketing
was harry potter with guns as opposed to
specifically violent
yeah but it got taken down by warner
brothers because he posted the whole
movie right yeah that was the trailer
taken down it's still up
i think the trailer got taken down too i
don't know for a fact but i do know that
rips of it are online right now
okay maybe you can go watch the video
but it's not on his original channel
anymore okay because
making like taking the movie down makes
sense because like
that could be a substitute for just
watching the whole harry potter movie
but
and it's like the extent of the fair use
doesn't quite extend to all of the
scenes without wands
there are a lot of scenes without wands
yeah but if it's just a trailer like
that's
what's the term uh where you change
something parody
uh well it's also um
yeah you know what i'm trying to say
it's it's different enough
where it's i don't know i know the time
you're looking for now i can't think of
it transferring none of that
transformative yeah yeah it's got to be
transformative
that's the word that jake likes to use
it's gotta be true resonant lawyer
that's like ascension dude
yeah like when you when you say it's
gotta be transformative like you have to
ascend
to this level like i just it's like wow
that person went so
far that they like transformed
themselves
we all had epiphanies last week before
we started this video
yeah well what were they transformative
of course
what's the latest epiphany you guys have
had
the latest epiphany yeah like genuinely
let me think about this oh boy dude
oh my oh i mean the epiphany to learn
cinema 4t is a big one
that i started at the top of this year
i'm so glad you're learning it yeah
awesome it's been fun it's also like
it's pretty it's i'm starting to get
into it a lot more so
i would have done it on these effects
but like i guess my thing is like
the reason why i've avoided it for so
long is because i'm like i've been
really good at after effects
and i kind of just like was able to
finagle my way into making visual
effects
that worked in 2d comps right so like
i guess it's like with anything though
it's like you know you you don't know
how to do
rigid bodies as well right or ragdolls
that's like all the rigid bodies
yeah so and even even on this podcast
you're like well maybe i don't do that
this time
yeah and it's really just a time thing
you know we have to think about the time
crunch that we're on as well and we
can't
necessarily learn new programs or new
techniques
in in a tight little window yeah so yeah
for me i'm like
oh i can do these 2d comps i can make i
can finagle some way to make this
these shots work dude i was the same way
for the longest time like i spent i
don't even know how many years before i
ever even opened my first 3d program it
was just all afternoon
yeah because like at the time i didn't
even know the difference between
different texture maps like
all of it was just black magic to me and
that was after i had released
several videos on my youtube channel
with visual effects in them
and like you know the mass public they
don't know the difference between after
effects and a 3d program like
cinema 40 or blender but to me it was
like that's everything different
and it was like i would always try to
like fake some 3d stuff like
using various tools in after effects and
then element 3d came out
and that was a big deal that was the
first foray into 3d that i ever did
i'm still confused
in general dude i'm just confused in
life
no element like i don't know how to get
in there dude me neither i never tried
yeah
no i didn't really like it element
elements good to like
teach you how 3d works like how
different texture maps work how like
3d space works and all that stuff and
you know you can't really you can't
model anything uh
but like it was it's really good for
like modifier type stuff if you want to
like
like and stuff the first time i ever did
like a 3d thing i made this nintendo
video several years ago i
remember watching that clip that exact
shot you're talking about like over and
over and over i was like this is the
coolest [ __ ] shot i've ever seen
thank you
yeah but okay so to explain it was just
like basically it was it was nintendo
wii
you know the classic wii the white
little like
brick it shatters it like it breaks into
like
a hundred pieces floating up above
and then those pieces reassemble into
the wii u
wait was this for was this for the
nintendo yeah remember that nintendo
challenge we did when we were nintendo
brand ambassadors yeah dude
i remember wait did you make a video
because i remember we both were in
brett's video
oh my god that was the funniest night
that was the we don't have to get into
that but that was the one of the
funniest cannot get into it now just
just look up look up uh
luigi's haunted mansion is that what
it's called yeah it's something like
luigi's haunted mansion brett skate yeah
it's on brexit because you're playing
luigi
and benji yeah from rocket jump was
playing mario and basically it was the
whole thing was improvised
because you were like uh you're kind of
i forgot how to act yeah it was like
really in my head and like super
paranoid and like i was like
i don't know like what are we doing and
and
benji was actually kind of getting
really annoyed like kind of getting
annoyed for real but instead he just
channeled that into his acting so it was
just like mario being like
you you brought in like him is like just
berating like you don't know yourself
grow a bear stand up put your hat on
come on
you are my brother and it's so
funny dude is this like a horror short
film yeah i've seen this i've seen this
is a
and jimmy jimmy wong was in the and he
was playing toad
and he was the guy that the two brothers
were trying to find
because luigi's haunted mansion his
battery got depleted and i'm like
coming out of the shadows and grabbing
people but i was i had makeup
all over my face and i just looked like
this bedazzled dude
and there's this photo that amanda got
of us sitting on the couch it was you me
jimmy
and and uh i don't i don't think brett
was in the shop but benji was there and
we're all in costume so mario luigi
uh toad and then me he's not really in
any identifiable costume but i've got
like
random blue and white paint yeah all
over my face with like little like
sparkly things
like the dazzle dress i was like this is
the most awkward photo ever because it's
like haha luigi and mario and like
who the hell is that it's like it just
rubbed
crest toothpaste all over your head
it was so weird we spent like all night
up in your attic like
filming this thing we were even done
until like three or four in the morning
dude and then we were like trying to
figure out how to get the wii u to work
and we couldn't figure it out
like how do you set this thing up dude
um
but yeah so going back to the wii u that
was it was they had they had like 20
different creators like make
make a little video for the wii u uh
launch or whatever and our payment was
we got a free wii u which was
cool i guess oh i know they flew us out
to sundance that was cool
i think that was sunday that's sweet you
were the sundance yeah
but from nintendo mm-hmm what mm-hmm
did they have a film or something no we
we did a film
48-hour film festival thing you did and
we premiered it at sundance
what yeah oh yeah that's insane yeah i
did
i did a rap battle i played as mario and
i did i rapped as mario
yes i did i forget the lyrics it was
like if you're getting corn then you
should pay us royalties for each and
every year throughout the years you've
shown us loyalty
oh whoa wow bars what dude that's insane
it's on the internet somewhere it's it's
it's awkward it's super awkward
yeah i'm sure it is uh yeah i'll be
watching this
oh that's all it takes to get into
sundance but hey back to epiphanies
oh yeah
i do right now not now i mean i do but i
didn't just have it right now oh okay
um crypto art getting in crypto
that was the only thing i was gonna say
like how how important and dire it is
for me to get into crypto
really oh yeah well yeah that was my
why is it dire yeah dire seems like a
strong word
because it's an opportunity because it's
a huge jeopardy loans that he needs to
pay
no it is it is a huge opportunity and
it's like it's it's popping off
and i can easily foresee within by the
end of the year everyone
is doing crypto art because it's like uh
it's it's so easy to see it as easy
money and that's the problem
because it kind of is but also it's like
not and so i think uh and i want to talk
a little bit more about that about how
because i've been getting messages i
don't know about you have but i've been
getting messages from people have you
considered the environmental concerns of
crypto
art and i'm just like what are you
talking about it's like yeah i
understand that like blockchain stuff
consumes a lot of energy but like i mean
yeah it's just a lot of energy
and then i read more into it and it's
actually kind of a lot
really every everything like the the
whole
everyone who has used uh like
mined bitcoin is it's like
more than the amount of energy than
argentina combined it's something close
to that it's like oh
put it look at it this way uh crypto
currencies
the blockchain in general consumes about
a hundred terawatt hours of energy
which is about half a percent of all of
the electricity generated in a year
on the planet wow just for
cryptocurrency
but that's that's that's that part and
um
but every uh uh nft
uh transfer and i'm i only read
this in-depth article once so i already
a lot of the details are starting to
become foggy but basically
every every transaction consumes a lot
of
energy to make sure to account for all
like the
to make the blockchain work because it
has to spread out through all the
different nodes
to make sure that everyone's public
ledger is the same so it has to update
everyone's
yeah and it's it's what makes the
blockchain so powerful and
and because everyone can trust it it's
as a public ledger sort of thing but
it's also
it's very power or it's very power
hungry to do that so
the amount of energy for one transaction
for like let's say you
purchased an nft something on the order
of 25
uh kilowatt hours which is a third of my
electric car battery
oh wow so one transaction is like
driving a tesla 100 miles
oh my god wow and that that's it's a lot
of energy yeah it's a lot of energy
i heard i heard they're coming out with
uh ethereum 2.0
that that is going to solve a lot of
that yeah uh
that's going to solve a lot of it
because so it's just coded differently
or something
it's the whole the problem comes down to
the proof of work aspect of
of blockchain technology is that it's
very
it's it's a lot of work and it requires
a lot of energy but if you can figure
out how to do that same amount of work
far more efficiently you're going to
consume less energy because that's the
whole the whole environmental aspect of
this is just the energy consumption side
yeah if if all of the energy is
renewable then there's no environmental
impact you can consume as much energy as
you want
but the problem is that most of our
energy is still derived from fossil
fuels
and that's where the environment
environmental impact comes from because
it's like all right
because you're consuming this much
energy that means this much
this many fossil fuels are being burned
whether it's natural gas
oil or coal and that means a certain
amount of carbon dioxide is being
um you know pumped into the atmosphere
and that's just exacerbating our climate
change problem right now
these are all facts and it's like okay
to what degree that
is a a problem is like
yo i wonder if like for every
uh piece of crypto art you sell you
plant a tree i mean hey
that i mean you can measure the amount
of of
the article i read broke down it's like
cryptoartwtf.com or something like that
i think
is uh the website and he's wrote in a
couple things and he goes into a lot of
detail about it
so i'm inclined to trust it but yeah i
mean you can offset it by
planting trees yeah that could just be
the culture you make a bunch of money on
crypto art you put some of it back into
the environment you know
i think that's like that could be
interesting but i think i think uh
ethereum 2.0
could be like a really nice investment
too because if it's like if it's green
then like why not buy a bunch
it's gonna get super popular and yeah so
the thing i'm struggling with is that
like
you know the the author of the article
was very clear to point out he does not
blame the artists
you know it's not it's not the artist's
fault it's the system's fault
and so he doesn't blame artists for
wanting to get into you know making
crypto art
i just realized we're talking about all
the environmental implications of crypto
art when you
likely have no idea what crypt art is
i just realized that talk about
epiphanies that's my epiphany oh my god
oh boy so crypto art is basically a way
to
buy digital art using the blockchain to
verify
that the piece of art you have is a
one-of-a-kind item
uh because blockchain is basically a
public ledger
uh everyone can verify that you know
this certain code is
an identifiable unique code and you can
tie that to a something like a piece of
digital art
and so people are buying these digital
pieces of art
under the like they have the exclusivity
to that because it's like
the argument is like why can't you just
like right click and say that it's like
yeah you can do that sure
same thing as you can take a picture of
the mona lisa and print it out and put
it on your wall it's not the mona lisa
though
um only one person can actually own the
mona lisa sure
and so that's this is kind of going into
like
art curation in the art industry as a
whole which has like a market cap of 70
billion
or something like that and it's a lot
and and the main difference between
that and crypto art is that with crypto
art because it's all the blockchain
every time a piece of art gets sold on
the secondary market the original artist
retains some royalties from it for every
single transaction wow it doesn't have
to be 10 it can be
upwards of 20 30 50 90 but the generally
accepted
amount is ten percent now let me ask you
as an
outsider to all of this what is the
advantage of owning something that
is unique to you like you you made the
comparison to a mona lisa but that's a
physical object yeah like
you own that painting but like
is the is like the render a higher
quality render than what you can just
save as
the okay i mean what is the advantage of
like it's just bragging rights basically
it's kind of it's an investment it's an
investment in like pure and simple
the way i see it is the investment the
investment has to happen
you're investing in something that has
to have value though but yeah and it's
only has value because everyone decides
it has value
okay and uh that's art yeah but like
uh generally you the person who buys the
token
the the minted piece of artwork uh
you're giving them the original raw
files and it could be you can even
include the project files if you so
feel like it uh or maybe it's just like
whatever you post to instagram it
doesn't quite matter
it's just the fact that you own the nft
the non-fungible
token uh which is a weird weird name
but yeah so it's like it's it's value
because it is the only one and the
artist
is also saying that my piece of art
that is the only one and everyone agrees
that that is the only one
and that value is derived from that and
i'm sure i'm not explaining this super
well but
pretty good helping me and so and so
it's just like the
the because everyone agrees okay wow you
got
you know the so-and-so's first piece of
digital art that
they have put on they don't they say
they only have one piece of digital art
up on the internet and that is it and
you got it wow good for you
um meanwhile they have an instagram page
with thousands of posts that they've you
know put up and you can right click
save as on all of them and print them
out so yeah it is the most common
question is like
why what's the point well it's an
investment like you can sell it for more
money if that artist if you
if you truly believe that that artist is
going to be more valuable in the future
then the price of the art that you
bought like 10 years ago
is gonna be a lot more expensive and
like you can sell it
and make and also the fact that it's all
based on
um cryptocurrency means it's invested
like your money is sitting there and
it's growing because the value of
bitcoin and the value of ethereum is
growing
yeah to be clear i know i kind of
started this whole conversation
talking about the environmental impacts
just because that's kind of at the
forefront of my mind this is something
i've been thinking about for a couple
months now
actually not a couple months a little
less than that ever since beeple made
his big splash a lot of people started
taking note because i'd seen it here and
there but i hadn't really given it any
thought i was like oh whatever i don't
know but then
when you start seeing like numbers
flying around with like millions of
dollars like wait what are you doing
wait what so i mean yeah it's like not
that i expect to make millions of
dollars making
crypto art but like baby it looks like a
really cool way to
make what you want to make creatively
and also like
be able to make money from it so i think
there's a lot of potential there and i
think that's
going back to what i said earlier i
think that's why we're going to see a
lot of people
getting into crypto art this year
especially after our video
gets public about it we made a whole
crypto art video with people
um which should be coming out in about
two weeks actually by the time you
uh that you're hearing this probably
about one week yeah maybe it's already
out if this video is older than a week
that video's already
online yeah i'm excited for that yeah it
should be pretty cool we did
we did a whole charity auction thing so
honestly we're still trying to figure it
out but what clint was saying
about the investment thing is that like
it's it's
so many people are buying a piece of art
because they think the creator is going
to continue
creating more stuff and become more
renowned and so those earlier pieces are
going to grow in value with the creator
and so people are investing by buying a
piece of art because they think it's
going to grow in value it's the same
sort of thing like oh i'm going to
invest in this company
because i think they're going to grow in
value so i'm going to put a little bit
of money into them
and whatever percentage share of the
company i get is going to grow
um or you know what i mean so it's yeah
the thing about
crypto art is that for the first time
ever it's it's actually kind of turning
people
into publicly traded companies well wild
wow
that so that sort of idea is really cool
so yeah i know clint and i are both
super into it right now we've already
gotten on to all the platforms or
i haven't actually applied to any of the
platforms yet i've just made my username
i'm in the process of submitting my
application because you actually have to
submit
an application to become an artist on
these platforms
geez well because it does take so much
effort
and and you know energy to actually
produce an nft
is it is it wrong to compare this to
like say
the youtube of like the art gallery kind
of world
where it's like that's wrong you have
your specific channels right and
in the early days of youtube it's like
well now how do we make money off of
this
and then you grow your audience and now
you have a platform that's specifically
yours
that you can like gain revenue from well
it's like
the only person you're counting on to
um to grow in the crypto art space
is besides yourself is
the website to stay yeah afloat sure
much like youtube right yeah where it's
like yeah it's just up to you kind of
had to invest in that
website right yeah yeah so interesting
but that's partly why i've started
producing a whole bunch of renders over
the last month or so
it's just like i have this new computer
at home and i want to start making a lot
more stuff so like in my free time
that's pretty much all i've been doing
is just trying to get better at
cinema 4d and just like post more stuff
they've been looking awesome
that uh the like metallic cubes in the
red was super sweet
it's gorgeous thank you uh but yeah i
mean clint though
is like every single saturday you do a
whole live stream where you just make
something
wow you get really into you've developed
a really cool community so much work
so much work i think the i mean i think
the coolest thing
that has come out of that whole year is
the fact that you made that one giant
render where all those artists submitted
like some of the coolest artworks
i've ever seen oh that was so cool i am
dying to do another one do it
i want to do it if you do another one
i'll just participate you guys promise
yeah absolutely promise yeah yes you're
going to get that pinky in here dude
you saw it you saw it and you're going
to learn c4d oh i'll learn something
yeah i really want to do another one i'm
super excited and your first video
popped off
have you seen this view count the first
which one first video the the the one
the with the dude walking away from
camera
the one we're talking about yeah where
everyone montage yeah yeah four million
yeah that's amazing it's freaking yes
i'm so i couldn't be more excited about
it like
it's the best there's a lot of people
who who like are very
very talented artists who are like far
better artists than i am in terms of
like
like technical skill sets creative eye
taste all that stuff and it's like i
know i get a little bit of imposter
syndrome sometimes i'm like man they're
already so good what chance do i have
i don't wish i even tried oh no man yeah
no you gotta go everyone's on their own
journey
yeah yeah but it's like what's cool is
that you got all these amazing artists
who are like
clint you're the man i'm going to make
something for you oh it's crazy dude
like it's like
i got a discord and everyone's on the
discord and they're well i gotta get on
that discord by the way everyone's just
like
give send me an invite yeah i mean it's
on every video that i have
well then okay that makes it easy then
um but basically yeah everyone's on
there and like we do a weekly challenge
every week this week is star wars so
okay render your sickest star wars
render and i
pick five winners and i like review them
at the end of every live stream and then
like i mean you know you were on one of
them
um but um yeah it's very exciting very
very exciting
maybe maybe this saturday maybe i don't
know what we're doing
we got to make it official and let's put
out a blast so you can tell it's like
officially you know what i mean we'll
talk we'll figure it out i think i could
probably do that yeah we'll wrap it up
we'll wrap it up um before we do though
peter
what's the epiphany give us an epiphany
that's right
you were you weren't thinking the whole
time about what your epiphany was
wow i this is kind of crazy
but i just thought i don't know if any
of you guys have heard this before but
like
but his legs what what
son what do you bite his legs that's how
you end the pun
i saw that joke from hank green continue
okay um
i was holding a five dollar bill in my
hand
and i i looked at this five dollar bill
and i looked over at my roommate
my friend riley and i was like man
friendship is more important than money
well
oh yeah and then so do you
tell he doesn't pay you rent for a few
too many times i tore it up instead of
pocketing in the truck have you been
tested
though have have you been put to the
test to put that realization to the test
you'll need to test me
yeah are you negative
[Laughter]
um he's negative for money that's for
sure he's negative for five dollars
i don't understand the point is this a
bill that he gave you
are you about to give him it's just an
epiphany dude oh i see i see
you're just saying no i i'm just being
facetious i don't have an epiphany
no i'm sorry i started digging into that
way too hard no i did have it
peter i think this is a great that's a
great lesson for us to take away from
this podcast
that um friends are more more important
than
uh keeping a five dollar bill mm-hmm
that you could have otherwise spent on
like a
matcha or something yeah i could have
even bought him a matcha yeah you could
have bought it and watching it actually
that would have been a better
friend move yeah yeah i'm pretty sure
that friend would have appreciated a
matcha instead
of just like you're actually right about
this i think you're a bad friend for not
doing that
yeah you got to rethink your epiphanies
anyway
that was our podcast
february 21st 2021 harry potter rated
ours releasing the day after
we release harry potter vfx artist react
coming out february 20th it's a big
weekend
if you haven't noticed we've been trying
really hard to make big action-packed
weekends with tight end vfx artists
react and
crew videos and when does this podcast
drop brandon uh
that thursday thursday 19th 18th check
this podcast out on thursday
yeah hey this thursday right now you're
checking this podcast out yeah guys
i'm looking forward to seeing i'm
looking i'm hoping you guys are looking
forward to seeing this podcast here
so it's so obvious we don't have jake
you got to start playing music yeah oh i
can't do it can you play
sorta okay we're just gonna get cut off
no we're christian's just gonna cut us
off
already cut us off that's up to him not
yet
[Music]
problems again
girl problems lyrics come on ryan
no i just learned no lyrics
that was a podcast we're done with it
now
i can't like improve
a good weekend and i appreciate all of
you love y'all